all right so now um that's part one i'm
done what do i do with part two well you
can see it is proofed by mathematical
induction that's required and i'm just
going to rehearse this for you because
it's not too complicated in fact i would
say this is going to be algebraically
simpler than almost any other proof by
induction you would do in extension 1 or
extension 2
let's have a go at it together you guys
know three basic steps in every proof by
induction right test assume prove so
let's start out with a test of the base
case and the base case in this case
the base case in this case you can see
it's defined there n is greater than or
equal to 1 so i'm just going to say test
for n equals 1.
that statement right all the x's are
independent of that n so they all just
stay in place right
the statement will tell us that the
number of ways
is going to be
equal to x outside of x minus 1
this x squared minus three x plus three
which we got from part one is still
there and now i substitute in n equals
one so it's one take away one that's it
you can see remember this is a proof so
i'm not going to skip anything i've
still got x squared minus 3x plus 3 but
it's been raised to the power of 0 which
is just equal to 1.
and that is the x times x minus 1 that
they told us not to prove for choosing
the colors of the first column so i can
just say therefore is true
for the base case n equals one happy
times
okay uh what are we then going to assume
well we're going to assume that the
statement is true for that arbitrary
choice of n and we're going to assign
that the letter k as is customary so
let's assume
that there are x times x minus 1
x squared minus 3x plus 3 to the power
of and now i'm going to substitute in my
arbitrary pronumeral k minus 1
ways
to color or to paint
and what is the size of this grid we're
substituting in k for n so i'm going to
say to paint a 2 by
k
grid
full stop
there's my assumption okay now what do i
have to prove i need to prove
something very similar to what i had in
my assumed step but for the k plus one
um case right so that k minus one index
is going to be replaced by k plus one
minus one so just a k and then instead
of being thinking about a two by k grid
i'm gonna think about it two by k plus
one grid so let's just make the
adjustments that we need to there so you
can see that's going to drop off there
and then over here instead of a k
wide grid i've got a k plus one
wide grid
how do i do it okay now
blink and you'll miss it right you
really just have to use the assumption
and combine it with part two or part run
one rather because we're in part two
right now so the way i'm going to use
the assumption is i'm just going to say
consider the first n columns or the
first k columns rather
the first k columns are their own 2 by k
grid which i can just use the assumption
for right
consider the first
k columns there are
and i'm just going to grab this
expression up above there are this many
ways
to color it or to paint it
um and i just what's my reasoning for
that like always i can say by the
inductive hypothesis or i can just say
by assumption and um i'm lazy so i'm
going to take the second option because
it's just shorter to write and shorter
to say
so that's that part and now i just have
to worry about the k plus one
column right like i've covered the first
k columns now i just need to deal with
the last one so the k plus one column
how many ways can it be colored and i'm
very simply going to rely on part one
which didn't talk about like all the
independent like it didn't didn't matter
how many columns we had previously we
just had to think about what was the one
previous to that right because
everything else is not adjacent so you
don't need to worry about it right so
the k plus 1 column can be painted in
how many ways
in
it's this part right here right
x squared minus 3x plus 3
ways and my justification for that my
substantiation for this claim is part
one proved
right so therefore i can now just
combine them together by multiplication
i told you there was not much algebraic
that you need to worry about the total
number of ways is going to be equal to
don't skip anything the number of ways
to do the first k columns there it is
and then i'm going to multiply by the
number of ways to do the final column
which is right here but i better chuck
some brackets around that whoops
for
good measure okay so therefore i can say
well i'm just going to put this together
with my index laws i've got x minus 1
and x out the front and then x squared
minus 3x obviously daisy not a k
to the power of k as required
i told you it was straightforward right
um but it is much more intimidating than
it looks because you've got all this
language to try and um sift through but
this you can see why for those of you
when i got into your breakouts i said
you know what don't don't worry about
too much about part two they were pretty
easy two marks and there's nothing um
dramatic here i was just proving it for
you here
and of course i'm going to conclude i
was just proving it for you here for the
sake of completeness okay so it's true
by the principle
of mathematical induction and i always
like to include the domain in my final
little conclusion here for
n is greater than or equal to one full
stop
in how many ways can a two by five grid
be painted if three colors are available
pause let's just have a look at that
part of the question before we deal with
this other bit which we said was
different because this part of the
question the first half i can just
answer in a very straightforward way
using parts one and two right or not
even part one right
what's the relevant k and what's the
relevant x in this question because
that's all i need to substitute into
right well i think you can see or you
could call it n if you like
in how many ways can a two by five grid
be colored so you can see this here it
stands for um how wide it is right so
this is either your n or your k i mean
those both stand for the same thing
right then you've got your number of
colors and so that's going to be think
about it your only other pronumeral you
need to deal with here is x so we
already said x has to be bigger than one
because you need a couple of colors at
least to color this thing and not have
adjacent things be equal so they've set
x is equal to three so all i'm going to
do here for my proof or to to obtain a
number i should say
i'm going to say from part two because
we proved the result for any arbitrarily
wide grid right um i'm going to say uh
i'm going to substitute in that k or
that n equals five and the x equals
three oh okay yes thank you thank you
for the person who posted in the in the
chat privately but they didn't want to
spoil anything for anyone i'm totally
okay with that as well um okay from part
two right the grid or the two by five
grid i should say
can be painted in how many ways
uh let me finish writing my sentence
here okay let's just go back to that
result right it was x x minus 1
x squared minus et cetera et cetera et
cetera so i'm going to take all of that
with my x equals 3 and my k equals five
or my n equals five so here we go here
comes the x here comes the x minus one
here comes the x squared take away
three lots of x there's a lot of threes
um plus three
and then i'm going to raise it to the
power of this is where the n comes in
right so or the k so this is going to be
five
take away one okay so you're like uh
gross there's some messy numbers here
but it's actually not that bad right
you're gonna get 3 times 2 out the front
this 3 squared and this 3 times 3
they're just going to cancel with each
other so that's kind of nice
and then you can see
i'm going to get a 3 raised to the power
of
oops it is you don't know why i colored
that so 3 to the power of 4 there okay
so you got 6 times 3 to the power of 4
some of you might know is actually 81
and you're like i don't even need a
calculator for this at least i hope you
don't that's
486 ways
okay now several of you have noticed
that this can't be right because i've
only taken into account half of the
question right this is just for a two by
five grid with three colors but this
includes not necessarily using all the
colors and that's what this question has
explicitly stated at once each color
must now be used at least once right so
think about this this 486 right what it
includes is well there's no way to color
it with just one color yeah because then
you'd have adjacent things um
side by side with the same color
matching and that's not allowed but you
can have there are a few ways to color
this grid such that you only use two
colors and uh you can think about how it
would alternate right and we don't want
to include those um they are included in
this number here but we need to remove
them from the count because they don't
meet this condition of using every color
at least once yeah
so here's the way that i went about
thinking about it again just like with
part one i thought a diagram would help
me i want to know how many of these two
color designs need to be removed well
what does a two color design look like
and hopefully without reasoning too far
you can see it's going to be some
version of this right even if it's not
these exact colors if you chose green
and blue
once you've got those two there
you have to use if i'm limiting myself
to a two color design you have to use
green and blue again but you just flip
them upside down so that adjacent colors
aren't beside aren't equal to each other
right and then you flip it again and
then you flip it again and then you flip
it again if you've only got two colors
to play with you've got no more choices
right so in fact what i'm trying to say
is that once you've chosen the colors of
your first column the other columns have
already kind of been determined for you
so really to work out the number of two
color designs i really just need to know
what's the number of ways to choose the
first
columns colors once you've chosen the
first columns colors if you limit
yourself to that you'll cover every
single possible two color design okay
so did you did you follow that um so i'm
now going to try and work out how many
there are to remove so there are
uh well i've got three colors to choose
from right so it's that x times x minus
one so that's three times two
ways to color the first column
and that means that there are three
times two ways
to use only two colors i don't know why
i'm put such a big space there there are
three times two ways to color everything
using the colors of the first column
okay so therefore there are i'm sure see
there are
six
total ways
or
six total two color designs
and these are the ones which i'm not
allowed to have right because i'm
supposed to have designs that use all of
the colors all together so i just take
my big number the 486 that i calculated
right here and then i just remove these
guys and everything that's left will
need to use three colors so i'm going to
say
in conclusion
um
number of ways
with all colors
is going to be equal to that 486
take away the six that i just calculated
so that gives you this number right here
full stop
well
did it run the time and yes good job
varen you put your money where your
mouth was and um it's saved on the
recording for all posterity okay so
congratulations
was this a hard question well when you
take stock of looking at like the
complexity of um
the numbers here
absolutely not but i think in many ways
that you people got intimidated by this
question or they felt like they just
didn't have enough time to think through
what was going on and so they didn't
even get to the point of trying to
actually put pen to paper
and work out what was happening so
classic example of where the logic and
the thought is the important part and
then how to communicate that once you've
got it
hopefully the way that i've set up my
proof is pretty
convincing and self-explanatory okay